denn wir warten auf die ersten prognosen
der unterhauswahl in großbritannien die
wahllokale machen da in fünf minuten zu
und wir schauen gleich mal was sich da
ergeben hat an erster umfrageergebnissen
an den wahllokalen und wir sprechen
unsere korrespondentin diana zimmermann
in london die steht nämlich und wird das
ganze mit uns gleich mal einschätzen wo
se
wir wollten erst mal zum bbc schatten
richtig die wbc ist gerade live drauf
aber zeigt uns auch nur ein schönes
vorwahl bild wahrscheinlich
dann würde ich sagen schalten wir mal
rüber zu diana die dort steht im winter
licht beim örtlichen london hallo diana
die ganze wahrheit china bisschen schon
gelaufen zu sein eigentlich den letzten
tagen dass da einiges passiert kannst du
mal kurz zusammenfassen was sich da auf
einmal ergeben hat ja der vorsprung der
konservativen unter boris johnson hat
sich leicht verringert der lack
zwischendrin eigentlich relativ konstant
bei zehn zwölf manche uns
umfrageinstitute haben sogar gesagt 17
und den letzten tagen hat er sich leicht
verringert immer noch liegt die
konservative partei deutlich vorn in den
gesamt umfragen also die sozusagen die
gesamtbevölkerung betrachten nunez haben
wir aber hier ein mehrheitswahlrecht und
da wird es eben nicht nur auf die
prozentzahl ankommen sondern vor allem
darauf wie viele wahlkreise die
konservativen für ihren kandidaten
entscheiden können denn nur der kandidat
der die meisten stimmen auf sich vereint
zieht ins britische parlament ein
und die frage ist eben tatsächlich ist
es aber gelungen so weit auszuschließen
dass die absolute mehrheit für boris
johnson in gefahr ist und diese absolute
mehrheit brauchte er unbedingt denn es
gibt keinen koalitionspartner für ihn
wenn er also keine absolute mehrheit hat
kann er nicht regieren und dann wird es
vermutlich eine regierung unter einer
koalition aus den oppositionsparteien
oder einer geduldeten
minderheitsregierung geben okay das
wahlsystem in uk ist nämlich ein
bisschen anders
hast du gerade schon angedeutet als bei
uns und da fällt immer wieder das
stichwort vom taktischen wählen und
andreas stamm hat uns mal
zusammengefasst was das heißt servus aus
london es ist mal wieder wahltag im
vereinigten königreich das kommt den
jüngster zeit häufiger vor und die
umfragen sehen
johnson und seine konservativen vorne
aber das hiesige mehrheitswahlrecht das
system nach dem gewählt wird das macht
es spannend trotz allem warum
es gibt 650 wahlkreise insgesamt also
ein bisschen anders als bei uns ich
mache mal hier ein paar wahlkreise und
dem jede
dieser wahlkreise gewinnt der kandidat
kandidat mit den meisten stimmen
der zieht ins parlament alle anderen
gucken möhre was im extremfall heißt man
ein beispiel kandidat hat in einem
wahlkreis tausend stimmen auch 1000 oder
2000 und eine stimmen dieser man geht
ins parlament die zwei scheiben aus und
die 2000 stimmen sind für die katz das
heißt dass das kann sein und das ist
durchaus nicht unüblich dass eine partei
die eigentlich nur 35 prozent der
stimmen hat landesweit trotzdem die
absolute mehrheit also über 50 prozent
der parlamentssitze ergattert und darauf
hofft boris johnson
aber wie trügerisch wie launisch dieses
wahlsystem sein kann zeigt folgendes es
gibt sagen wahlforscher 36 wahlkreise
sind extrem umkämpft und in diesen 36
wahlkreisen braucht es nur 40.000 wähler
die taktisch wählen und schon wäre boris
johnsons mehrheit futsch taktisch wählen
heißt ich will jetzt nicht den
kandidaten der mir eigentlich am
liebsten ist von der partei die ich am
meisten mag sondern ich wähle den
kandidaten in diesem fall der am ehesten
es schafft eine mehr zusammen zu kriegen
um den kandidaten der konservativen zu
schlagen und somit eben johnsons
mehrheit zu verhindern
leute wie hugh grant zum beispiel machen
werbung dafür klingt furchtbar
kompliziert macht es aber eben auch
unglaublich spannend genau spannend ist
es eine minute noch diana da hast du
noch kurz zeit uns zu sagen war das
jetzt tatsächlich in ding heute oder
letzten tagen in uk oder ist es eher
wunschdenken von labour gewesen
das ist hier tradition allen dingen weil
die leute eben wissen dass nur ein
kandidat ins parlament einzieht und es
war tatsächlich ein großes ding heute
haben allein auf einer dieser webseiten
wo man eingeben kann in welchem
wahlkreis man lebt 300.000 leute ihre
postleitzahl an gegeben um
herauszufinden für welchen kandidaten
sie stimmen müssen um einen
konservativen kandidaten und damit den
exit womöglich noch zu verhindern so
diana die schalten jetzt mal zwei babys
ihr über denn in
15 sekunden sollte die ersten ergebnisse
kommen die sind ähnlich straight wie wir
wenn wir wahrhaben und ich bin mal
gespannt ich hasste minute durften die
nudel okay ich habe hier noch ein paar
sekunden aber wir sehen guck mal da ist
big ben und da wird vielleicht 22 uhr
geschlagen und da kommen die ersten
zahlen
also eine konservative mehrheit von 368
zu 191 labour das sagen die probleme
hand und westlich der b 268 grad 68 291
das während die sitze ist wenn ich das
richtig sehe oder sind das die das sind
das wären die sitze im unterhaus sind
die sitze ja genau das heißt es ist aber
eine halskette mehrheit
das hat ja im grunde den drexhage sogar
der kleine schon mal in die
geschichtsbücher schreiben ja das können
wir hier mit dass es eine sehr deutliche
mehrheit für boris johnson da kann sich
auch bei dem normalen fehler raum der
sich über den über die nacht noch ergibt
eben über durch die auszählung der
wahlkreise nicht mehr viel ändern also
nicht mehr daran dass er eine absolute
mehrheit hat er hat gewonnen und damit
tritt der exit am 31
januar in kraft er hat eine große
mehrheit das ist wenn ich das richtig
sehe eine der besten ergebnisse für die
konservativen konservative partei seit
über 30 jahren das ist natürlich ein
ziemlich starkes stück zumal die labour
partei noch mal richtig gelitten hat
wenn ich das sehe 191 ist wirklich ein
sehr schlechtes abschneiden und das
spricht natürlich dafür dass der labour
kandidat jeremy copp in wirklich
überhaupt nicht gezogen hat so wie viele
in großbritannien das schon lange sagen
der hatte zwar eine große fanbasis in
seiner eigenen partei aber in der
breiten bevölkerung kam er eben
überhaupt nicht andere hat boris johnson
auch spekuliert und sehr viel wahlkampf
damit gemacht und er hat damit reduziert
jekabs die frage von d die auf youtube
ob die ersten prognosen einigermaßen
präzise sind kannst du da was zu sagen
ja also im gegensatz zu den umfragen die
hier in den letzten jahren sehr wenig
präzise waren sind diese prognosen die
darauf beruhen dass in wahlkreisen leute
nochmal den wahlzettel ausfüllen wenn
sie gerade schon gewählt haben
normalerweise sehr sehr akkurat da gibt
es ein fehler martin von ungefähr fünf
prozent also ich gehe nicht davon aus
dass sich das an der tatsache das
produktionsteam heute abend eine
absolute mehrheit errungen hat noch mal
was ändert ja selber user schreibt
gerade jetzt können sich die briten
zumindest nicht mehr damit herausreden
sie hätten nicht bescheid gewusst
pascal hat ihr mann gerade of parents
kopf nochmal gefragt rexit verhindern
ich dachte der zug ist abgefahren ganz
abgefahren sollte er nicht gewesen sein
zumindest nicht wenn es nach mir
gegangen wäre also wenn tatsächlich
heute abend diese unglaubliche
überraschung stattgefunden hätte und
lorenz sonst sind die absolute mehrheit
verfehlt hätte dann hätte er eben keine
regierung bilden können weil es keine
koalitionspartner für ihn gegeben hätte
und dann hätten die oppositionsparteien
das ruder an sich gerissen und die
hätten nächstes jahr ein zweites
referendum abgehalten wie das
ausgegangen wäre wissen wir nicht und
das ist tatsächlich jetzt auch
geschichte
das wird nicht stattfinden wir können
mal kurz zur bbc über schalten ich habe
die mir mal hier auf meinem desktop
gelegt da sind die expertin sieht es
also wie viele sitze bekommt wer
konserve tipps während 368 ein fettes
plus von 50 sitzen labour 191 - 71 sitze
die liberalen demokraten den libdems
kommen auf 13 sitze und der rest snp da
mussten wir kurz helfen das sind glaube
ich die sozialdemokraten würden
die schottischen nationalisten die
glaube ich auch eigentlich für die
nationalisten die haben 20 dazu gewonnen
das ist exzellent das heißt schottland
ist ein und es wird den titel nicht so
da kann ich kann nicht gleich was genau
und die sind jetzt noch mal noch viel
deutlicher gegen den wechsel was das
auch bedeutet ist dass die forderungen
aus schottland nach einem zweiten
referendum oder deren unabhängigkeit mit
sicherheit in den nächsten monaten immer
lauter werden denn die schotten sind
gegen den bhc wechselte haben immer
gesagt sie wollen nicht von
großbritanien dazu gezwungen werden
einfach mit auszutreten obwohl sie das
nie wollten und jetzt kommt boris
johnson mit seinem ziemlich harten
dragset und gleichzeitig bekommt nicolas
deutschen in schottland einen macht zu
gewinnen
da kann man schon eine erste konflikte
hier sehen die schotten werden
tatsächlich darauf dringen dass es bald
ein zweites referendum bei ihnen gibt
das allerdings von london zugestanden
werden muss die frage kommt nämlich auch
gerade hier von yovite.com fluss
referendum der schotten was es mit den
iren aber kann so ein zweites referendum
bei den schotten überhaupt irgendwas
bewirken oder können die sich vielleicht
sogar von uk abspalten und sagen wir
möchten aber in der eu bleiben also das
hat nicolas dort schon immer gesagt am
liebsten würde sie einfach bleiben
während die briten gehen
deswegen möchte sieht das referendum
auch gern schon nächstes jahr abhalten
bis großbritannien tatsächlich auch von
den regeln her von der eu abgekoppelt
ist die legale abkopplung wird eben
jetzt am 31 januar stattfinden dann
kommt aber die übergangsphase und da
ändert sich erstmal nichts dran
die andere idee ist dass schottland in
wieder einzeln beitreten müsste da gibt
es dann probleme mit den spaniern die da
kein exempel statuieren wollen für die
katalanen
das ist alles sehr spannend aber wir
können ganz klar festhalten dass das
eine der zukünftigen konfliktlinien im
königreich sein wird ist das denn eine
absolute mehrheit für boris johnson 368
sitze also post 50 für alle die jetzt
klar das einschalten boris johnson hat
hier fed zu gewonnen während labour
party mit jeremy copp in sehr deutlich
verloren ist das jetzt quasi
der die grüne karte dass er machen kann
was er möchte ja das ist die grüne karte
und jetzt gibt es tatsächlich zwei
interessante überlegung es ist klar es
wird am 31 januar ausgetreten aber dann
ist eben gar nicht klar wie es
weitergeht mit dem verhältnis zur eu und
eine hoffnung die man haben kann aus
europäischer sicht sozusagen und aus
sicht der vielen briten im land die eben
gar keinen drechselt wollten ist dass
johnson ein bisschen in die mitte rückt
und von seinem harten wechselt ein
bisschen abrückt weil er natürlich
wiedergewählt werden will bei den
nächsten wahlen und deswegen die
wirtschaft natürlich gerne am laufen
halten möchte
jetzt kann er sich nicht jetzt muss er
sich nicht mehr von den rechten flügel
in seiner partei erpressen lassen er
muss nicht mehr den harten mann geben
die frage ist natürlich nur wenn jemand
mit populismus so weit gekommen ist wie
er
ob er dann wieder davon ablassen kann
das werden wir in den nächsten monaten
beobachten so jetzt gibt es hier ein
bisschen eine hämische kommentare auf
youtube in den letzten tagen hieß es die
labour-partei hatte aufgeholt haben die
medien mal wieder mit dem vorhersagen
wie bei der tramp fall versagt ja muss
man dazu sagen unsere vorhersagen sind
das ja nicht die haben wir auch von
umfrageinstituten bekommen also dass wir
uns nicht aus sondern die haben das ja
herbei gefragt ja genau das haben sie
wir haben immer wieder gesagt dass die
umfrageinstitute in den letzten jahren
immer wieder falsch gelegen haben aber
sie haben ja diesmal nicht so falsch
gelegen sie haben alle bis zum schluss
gesagt boris johnson bekommt auf jeden
fall eine mehrheit und fast alle haben
die ganze zeit gesagt es wird auch für
eine absolute mehrheit reichen die frage
war nur wie knapp und tatsächlich können
wir jetzt sagen es ist überhaupt nicht
knapp es ist eine sehr fette mehrheit so
noch ganz kurz eine frage die hier oder
eine statement assen stream auf facebook
gestellt wurde von norman der schreibt
labour hat einfach keine klare position
bezogen
zum rexit ist gemeint
labour-chef corbijn hat immer gesagt ich
bin neutral aber ich möchte noch mal
abstimmen lassen meinst du das wäre es
tatsächlich ein problem gewesen
ein riesenproblem also labour hatte
verschiedene probleme aber das war eine
riesiges problem dass hier über drei
jahre lang und im grunde genommen schon
vor dem referendum nicht klar war welche
position labour einnimmt und vor allen
dingen welche position der
spitzenkandidat einnimmt der
traditionell im parlament als
hinterbänkler immer gegen jede weitere
vertiefung der beziehungen zur eu
gestimmt hatte der dann seiner partei in
der kampagne gefolgt war und gesagt hat
okay ich bin auch für den verbleib in
der eu aber wirklich völlig
leidenschaftslos und der daneben über
drei jahre lang sich nicht entscheiden
konnte welche positionen einnimmt und im
grunde genommen das bis zum schluss
nicht tun wollte
90 prozent der labour wähler wären dafür
gewesen den dragset abzusagen
in der partei allerdings gibt es eben
eine starke eu skeptische bewegung und
zu der gehörte core bin und das hat die
partei völlig zerrissen das hat ihren
außenauftritt beschädigt und das hat sie
ganz sicher sehr selbst stimmen gekostet
und eben auch das gefühl vermittelt dass
es eine partei ist die gar nicht weiß wo
sie hin will
diana zimmermann vielen dank für diese
ersten einschätzungen jetzt nach den
ersten prognosen aus dem vereinigten
königreich und wir sehen uns später noch
mal in unserer live sendung
und euch sagen wir auch vielen dank für
das einschalten für das kommentaren 1
comment habe ich mal kurz vor lesen da
beschwert sich jemand der sich die snp
partei gerade nicht zuordnen konnte das
tut mir leid ich bin auch nicht in allen
politikfeldern 100% firmen da bin ich
gerade mal überrascht worden aber
inkompetenz mir jetzt vorzuwerfen naja
gut
ihr seid live ich bedanke mich auf jeden
fall bei euch und wird sagen wir gucken
mal was wir jetzt mit diesem
wahlergebnis machen was in den nächsten
monaten passiert das wird extrem
spannend
und wenn ihr möchtet wir sind nachher
nochmal im fernsehen live und werden das
nochmal einordnen
dass jetzt aber erstmal vielen dank fürs
zu sehen macht's gut
[Musik]